all right starting today with some
genuinely very bad news for some
horrible people rudy giuliani and sydney
powell two of donald trump's former
election fraud
attorneys although to call them election
fraud attorneys
suggests that there might have been
fraud which we now know there wasn't but
both rudy and sydney have been
subpoenaed by the trump riot committee
the house committee investigating the
january 6th trump riots this is very bad
news for them and very bad news for
trump and sydney powell has not been
having an easy go of it newsweek
reporting rudy and sydney subpoenaed by
1 6 committee will they comply
the house committee investigating the
january 6 riot has subpoenaed rudy
giuliani
jenna ellis
sydney powell and boris epstein
all attorneys in the 2020 re-election
campaign of then-president trump it's
unclear whether any of them will comply
many of trump's former associates like
steve bannon and mark meadows have not
some have invoked the fifth amendment to
avoid testifying the committee wrote in
a tuesday evening tweet the four
individuals advanced unsupported
theories about election fraud pushed
efforts to overturn election results or
were in direct contact with the former
president the hill likewise reporting on
these subpoenas
saying that the subpoena goes after the
core
of trump's legal team after the november
third election a group that prepared
legal arguments following his loss and
pushed his baseless claims of election
fraud alongside campaign efforts on the
focused on the congressional
certification
the select committee is looking into the
causes that contributed to the violence
on january 6th including attempts to
promote unsupported claims of election
fraud and pressure campaigns to overturn
the 2020 election results the subpoena
to giuliani focuses on his ability to
offer insight into trump's state of mind
in the days around the riots as well as
his work pushing fraud claims on tv and
in courtrooms
the committee wrote you actively
promoted claims of election fraud on
behalf of former president trump and
sought to convince state legislators to
take steps to overturn the election
anna cabrera from cnn
reports that her that sydney powell's
attorney
says she will appear
before the january 6th committee and
answer questions but that powell also
still believes there indeed was
election fraud so this is potentially
a really really big deal and there's a
few different pieces to this that i
think are important
the first one is
it's very clear
that this if you imagine concentric
circles of sorts with donald trump at
the middle of that circle
the entire probe is getting closer and
closer to donald trump himself now
sidney powell
uh rudy giuliani
talking about you know records from
ivanka trump
and i'm sorry from eric trump and
kimberly guilfoyle and we're wondering
will they next go to ivanka trump and
don jr what's going on there it's very
clear that it's closing in but will
anything come of it the second piece of
this is the increasingly important
timing of the investigation into the
january 6th trump riots and the reason
that that's increasingly a factor
is that we are now only
nine and a half or so months from the
2022 midterms now as i've said before i
don't believe that any october surprise
stemming from the investigation
will really have an impact on the
midterms i just i can't it's hard for me
to imagine
what could come out of the report that
we don't
really kind of know already and
importantly
that would change the way republicans
would vote in the midterms i don't think
there would be anything but that doesn't
change the fact that if republicans do
take the house in november and are sworn
in in january the entire investigation
is over overnight the the committee's
disbanded if republicans take control of
the house in november so
it would be important even if it's not
going to change the minds of any
republicans to have a finished report
from the house select committee on the
january 6 trump riots before it's
prematurely ended if republicans indeed
do take control of the house in november
so those are the considerations
and the committee does seem to be moving
relatively quickly
as quickly as they can
and the question of what to do about the
people ignoring the subpoenas
is an important question and it takes
time to resolve that as the legal system
functions and moves forward
much more slowly than we would like but
not a good day for rudy giuliani not a
good day for sydney powell either
one of our sponsors is cometeer coffee
cometier coffee is delicious i can tell
you firsthand and they've discovered the
best way to brew preserve and deliver
coffee their brewing process captures
over two thousand flavor compounds then
the coffee is flash frozen locking in
the flavor it arrives at your home
frozen in a fully recyclable capsule all
you have to do is melt it by adding hot
water or cold water for iced coffee it
takes seconds it's the most convenient
way that i have ever made coffee i've
been impressed with how the process
protects the flavor i really enjoy
cometier they have a variety of flavor
options light medium and dark single
origin and blended coffee roasts from
the best specialty roasters you'll get
twenty dollars off when you go to
cometer.com
pacman the link is underneath this video